all right question that was asked
earlier this week that we wanted to get
to naya to thomas do the browns have the
best one-two running back punch in the
nfl shireen
what do you think nick chubb and kareem
hunt are they the best
well nick chubb finished second and
barely finished second last year for the
rushing title probably should have won
that rushing title of course kareem hunt
won it as a as a rookie so i i think you
have to say yes they rank uh
fourth and ninth right now in the league
in rushing and i just don't think
there's anybody that compares to them i
mean you look at the cowboys with
elliot and pollard that's decent the
steelers have connor and snell
the packers have uh jones and williams i
mean there's some there's some
good combinations but i just don't think
anybody has that
nick chubb kareem hunt combination that
that the browns have and they're going
to continue to run the football much to
the
dismay probably of odell beckham
although he says he's okay with blocking
as
gronkowski says he's okay with blocking
but they need to
run the ball that's that's their
strength right now with baker mayfield
at quarterback they've got those two
running backs who are fantastic
yeah kevin stepanski the coach of the
team said earlier today it's way too
premature to talk about blocking
receivers and running the ball versus
passing the ball they don't know how
each game is going to go and that's the
way that a team needs to be
every game should be its own plan based
upon who the opponent is and what you
think you're gonna be able to do
successfully frickin xd wants to know
our thoughts on the raiders patriots
game can vegas pull off the away game
upset personally i think their offense
has to be on fire
and the defense has got to make some
turnovers that's the question here's my
answer it's going to come down to derek
carr
is he going to unleash the ball down the
field when he has the opportunities
that's one of the things sims
has been pointing out that the
opportunities are there john gruden is
going to want
car to take them and you know that
patriots defense
got roasted a little bit last week by
the seahawks are they susceptible or
will they be determined
to keep it from happening again bottom
line is will derrick carr be determined
to throw the ball down the field and try
to move that offense and get the kind of
big plays
that can break the patriots back
i think he needs to have a healthy
darren waller and a healthy josh jacobs
too and of course they're questionable
they need to be at a hundred percent
because those are two of their biggest
playmakers they they're not going to get
the ball down the field but they're
certainly going to be a big part of that
offense so they need to be healthy and
help him out
and yeah i agree with that though they
got to have some turnovers
this this is a team that that if you
don't have the turnovers and have some
short fields that they're probably going
to have a tough time against patriots
and i think the patriots are going to be
determined to get back in the winning
column
after giving seattle everything they
could handle and believing they were
going to win that game right down
until the past or the last few seconds
of the game so i think the patriots will
be fine
but if the raiders pull this one off i'm
ready to sign on as a believer in the
raiders this year
last one real quickly at ginger bloke of
all the changes that
the jets need what's number one shireen
who i am you hate to say quarterback but
i mean this is a team that's 32nd total
offense
and i know he doesn't have great weapons
i i get all that
you know i guess you go back to what
bill parcell said you start building
with the offensive line and the
defensive line
and and make it work there but they need
a lot
they need more makai beckton's he's
looked good so far which is an
affirmation of what joe douglas the gm
of the team is doing
mike mc cagnan tried to build the team
from the outside in
the right way to do it is build it from
the inside out both lines of scrimmage
when you have a great offensive line and
defensive line
all those other players are going to
look a hell of a lot better and that's
what the jets need it just may take
a couple more years to get there and in
the interim they're going to lose plenty
of football games which means they'll
get some high draft picks all right